si la parole est à mme sur rémi delattre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre à des jo ce week-end
nous forces de l'ordre et de lutte
contre les incendies auxquels je redis
toute notre solidarité ont été l'objet
d'un guet-apens aux cocktails molotov
quand dans le même temps un surveillant
pénitentiaire de la maison d'arrêt de
dijon était prise en otage par un détenu
incarcéré pour radicalisation ces
attaques ne sont hélas pas isolé
mantes-la-jolie la seyne-sur-mer lorient
ou encore ma si une telle mise en danger
une telle agression de nos forces de
sécurité de ces femmes et ces hommes de
devoir dans le contexte de menaces que
nous connaissons appel à instaurer la
réponse ferme de l'impunité zéro face à
ces criminels
au-delà des mesures bienvenues mais
tardive que vous avez pu annoncer il
devient impératif de garantir la
sécurité des français et de ceux qui se
sont engagés pour les protéger en leur
apportant un soutien sans faille et des
moyens d'agir
monsieur le premier ministre les
propositions sont sur la table c'est le
rétablissement des peines planchers
c'est la révision de la légitime défense
c'est lé renforcement des moyens
matériels
c'est l'affranchissement de tâches
administratives qui détourna les agents
du terrain oh je ne suis pas en train de
dire que tout est facile monsieur le
premier ministre
mais il y a urgence et il faut du
courage au delà des discours qui souvent
renforce la colère et l'exaspération les
forces de l'ordre et nos compatriotes
vos conjure de restaurer l'autorité de
l'état dans tous les territoires de la
république
merci la parole est à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le député vous venez de poser
une question avec beaucoup de
pondération avec aussi beaucoup de
vérité dans les sujets que vous avez
évoqué je veux essayer d'apporter une
réponse qui soit la plus complète
possible dans un temps contraint le
premier point sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est sur le fait que vous avez
raison de dire que il y a un problème de
moyens et qu'il y ait un problème
d'effectif et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle depuis 2012 nous avons
souhaité réhausser le niveau des
effectifs de la police nationale de la
gendarmerie nationale à la fin de
l'année 2016 ce sont six mille huit
cents emplois qui ont été créés dans les
forces de l'ordre nous en créerons 2700
de nouveau en 2017 et ce sont donc 9000
emplois qui ont été créés pendant toute
la durée du quinquennat
vous insistez sur les moyens autres et
notamment les véhicules les armes les
moyens de protection vous avez raison
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
augmenté de 15% là aussi les crédits de
fonctionnement hors personnel de la
violence et de la gendarmerie
ce qui nous a permis de mettre en place
un plan de rééquipement des brigades
anti criminalité et le plan de 250
millions d'euros qui fera l'objet d'un
amendement parlementaire pour réhausser
l'augmentation déjà significative en loi
de finances pour 2007 17 permettra
d'équiper l'ensemble de la sécurité
publique et puis il ya d'autres sujets
le sujet de la légitime défense
nous présenterons des dispositions sur
la légitime défense
avant la fin du mois de novembre au
parlement comme je les dis à l'occasion
de l'examen de notre budget nous allons
faire de même sur l'anonymisation et
nous avons faire de même pour faire en
sorte que les outrages à forces de
l'ordre et à magistrat soit aligné dans
la loi voilà l'ensemble des questions
que nous traitons que nous avons sur le
métier
nous les traitons avec d'autant plus
d'énergie que vous êtes bien placé pour
savoir que dans une période qui n'est
pas si lointaine
treize mille emplois ont été supprimés
si un de la paix